[Music]
well that's scene from londontown
there's a reason for that we welcome you
back to cbs mornings where we're finding
out what some people in england think of
prince andrew's legal troubles they
involve his friendship with sex abuser
jeffrey epstein and a woman who claims
that andrew had sex with her when she
was under age last week queen elizabeth
removed many of andrew's courtesy titles
but not the one that he uses the most
that would be prince andrew holly
williams went to the place that inspired
that title to get some reaction
the city of york in northern england is
steeped in history medieval gothic horse
the biggest cathedral in the country on
our visit its medieval streets were
shrouded in fog as murky as the scandal
now engulfing prince andrew also known
as the duke of york i don't think he
should be the duke of york no we don't
want that you don't want that
association anymore
the dukedom of york is normally held by
the monarch's second son it was
conferred on prince andrew by his mother
the queen when he married in 1986. now
with his reputation sullied there's a
social media campaign to strip him of
the title if these allegations are true
he should pay the price
the english are famously reserved
and the monarchy here is overwhelmingly
popular but prince andrew has some
people boiling over when he's got
daughters of his own which makes it even
worse
he's got daughters of his arm you're
quite disgusted by what's happening the
all the english people are
everyone's disgusted
only this lady was somewhat sympathetic
to the prince it's not squeaky clean for
sure
but
you have to have some proof she's
probably a fortune hunter
in my opinion but
you know
there's no smoke without a fire she's
talking about virginia defray who claims
that jeffrey epstein trafficked her to
prince andrew and is suing the prince
alleging he sexually assaulted her on
multiple occasions when she was a
teenager
he denies the allegations has not been
charged with a crime and says he has no
recollection of ever meeting jeffrey
despite this photo of them together with
convicted sex trafficker glenn maxwell
i'm not in in an interview he claimed it
might have been doctored that is that is
what i would describe as as me in that
in that picture but i can't we can't be
certain as to whether or not that's my
hand on on her uh whatever it is left
left side you think that because i i
have no recollection of that photograph
ever being taken how can you not
remember and then the photographs there
the evidence is there everybody's seen
that so
saying that i don't sweat and i can't
remember meeting her and all that it
just doesn't ring true does it the queen
stripped prince andrew of all of his
honorary military titles last week and
he'll no longer be able to call himself
his royal highness i think it says to
the nation that for the monarchy to
survive this that she has got to remove
his official titles rachel rachel maskel
represents york in the british
parliament and told us if the prince
loses his court case and refuses to give
up his dukedom the government needs to
act
this isn't about the the court case
itself but this is about the insight
into his associations gila maxwell
jeffrey epstein and we know his history
it's all come out and drags us into that
story and as a proud city we don't want
to go there
his legal battle in the u.s is far from
over but the verdict on the duke of york
in this ancient city that shares his
name isn't favorable for cbs morning's
holly williams york
well i can appreciate their frustration
what a smart piece to do to see what
what do the people of york feel clearly
he doesn't seem to have a lot of support
with the exception of that one woman
yeah and i think she's in the minority
who think that virginia gouffrey is a
fortune hunter known in this country as
gold digger yeah i think that's the
minority position yeah very much i know
the power of social media can travel
around the world yes
not in york's name yes yeah and the
cultural differences of man on the
street interviews in america americans
look at the camera and they address it
you know they got a lot of animated the
british are a little more polite but
more reserved you know no no i don't
think you should no not really a nice
piece holly we appreciate it